Pound, uh, how many of you
have ever read pound before?
So yeah.
Uh,
w unlike frost,
you,
you are unlikely to have read
much, uh, uh, pound. I think, uh,
up to this point in your educations, uh,
and probably you are,
you are an, uh, uh, uh,
unlikely to have much of a view of
him in contrast to foster even Yates,
uh, who, uh, uh,
cuts such a particular and,
and a remarkable public
figure. A pound, uh,
can be hard to put together.
A, he can be hard to, um,
get a, get a picture of
what is pound like. Um,
what was he like? Uh, well,
uh, this is a, uh, uh,
a hard question for some of the
same reason that the poems are hard.
Uh, that is, uh, pounds, poetry projects,
no determinant identity,
uh,
no determinant poetic voice.
Unlike those,
those distinctive voices of Yeats
and pound. All right. Excuse me.
He hates and frost.
Instead a impound,
you encounter a
multiplicity of identities,
a multiplicity of voices,
right?
There's an interesting
contradiction in this.
Pound is a kind of fierce individualists.
Uh,
he believes in, he wants to honor
as a political thinker and as a,
uh, as a poet, a as a
reader. He wants to honor
heroic and sovereign idea
of the individual. Uh,
at the same time
in his writing,
pound repeatedly divest
himself of identity,
of particular identity,
uh,
in order to enter or to be
entered by other identities,
other poets, other voices,
uh, creators, a heroes.
This is what he wants to
give us access to as readers.
Pounds, uh, Sim,
Travelocity and modern poetry repeats
the kind of paradox I'm describing a that
is, he is the one poet on the syllabus
whom all the other poets, new,
uh, had some kind of relationship
with some kind of contact.
Um,
on the one hand,
a pound was an individual of extraordinary
personal charisma and force someone
who liked to and who had power
to tell other people what to do,
tell other people what to
think and what to value.
On the other hand, uh,
when you, uh, study pound,
you're studying someone a
remarkably open to others. Uh, uh,
in friendship, uh, as
a reader, a as a, uh,
thinker.
He's someone who openly
seeks alliance with others.
Uh, he has, uh,
we've already talked in our first lecture,
uh,
had an important relationship to
frost. Uh, you remember for us,
speaking of his sometime friend pound,
who wants to write as he puts it,
caviar to the crowd.
Um, well, uh, pound is, is credited. Uh,
as I also suggested with in
many ways modernizing Yates, uh,
helping Yates become, um,
the, uh, uh, particular, um,
uh,
voice that he did a in the teens
and twenties in [inaudible].
There's a little letter,
uh, a handwritten pencil,
a letter from pounds to Hart Crane,
which Hart Crane received when he was 18,
I think around your age.
After he had sent his poems to
the little review. And this is,
this is a letter from
pound, which says about, um,
Crane's poems.
It is all very egg.
There is perhaps better egg,
but you haven't the ghost of a
setting hen or an incubator about you.
I'm not sure what that
means. Uh, uh, but, uh,
this was a rejection slip. Uh, and
crane kept it all his life, uh,
like a kind of diploma, uh, that,
uh, you know, in some way. Uh,
he was a member of modern poetry because
he had gotten a rejection from Ezra
pound. Um, in fact, cranes first
book, if you go over to buying a key,
um, uh, and you, you turn
it over, it has, uh, a, um,
a picture. Uh, it has a
portrait, a not of Hart Crane,
but of Ezra pound, uh, because it has a,
an ad for pound and his
book persona. Um, and,
and I, I like this fact because it's
representative I think of, uh, of,
of pounds, importance and
dominance and prominence, uh, in,
uh, the poetic, uh,
culture of the 1920s and thirties.
He was part of the world that
a younger poet like Hart Crane,
uh, had to, uh, uh, get to
know and make his place in.
Um, uh, one of the famous
books about modern poetry,
uh,
one by Hugh Kenner is called simply the
pound era as if modern poetry was all
about ends or pound. Um, as we're pound,
uh, born in Hailey, Idaho, uh,
in 1908, uh, I like it that this, uh,
uh, wildly a cosmopolitan, uh,
ex Patriot intelligence
was born in Idaho. Uh, he,
uh, left the United States. Um, um, oh,
he wasn't born in 1908.
When was Pam born?
He left the United States
in 1908 look in your,
your 18. Yeah, 1885. Thank you. Um,
uh, he, uh, uh, he left, um,
the u s in 1908, uh, and
lived mostly in London, uh,
where, um, at that point, um,
where he acted as the foreign
editor of a poetry magazine.
Uh, and the little review too little
magazines that I've shown you,
a pictures, uh, of, uh,
and that, uh, were, um,
important in bringing modern
poetry to the United States.
A pound is the central figure.
In that process.
He goes out and finds and
interprets and explains,
and even in the case of images
of names, the poetry that, uh,
he is, uh, uh, bringing,
um, to American readers.
He is the, uh, the
entrepreneur, if you like,
behind images. Um, and then, uh,
when Amy Lowell takes over images
and vorticism becomes his thing,
uh, and, uh, uh, the magazine
blast becomes for a while.
Uh, his Oregon, uh, he,
he writes a manifestos,
uh,
he organizes groups all the time,
abandoning them to his poem.
Hugh Selwyn Moberly,
uh,
composed in 1920 looks back on this whole,
period in London, um, and, um, uh, is a,
is a kind of, um, um,
uh, well summary, uh,
of, um, the poetry of this period,
uh, and his involvement in it.
Uh, and, uh, it is itself a kind of, um,
early model for another great
poem, the wasteland, uh,
which, um, Elliot would, uh,
as he composed it bring two pound to,
uh,
edit and we'll talk about
that process in a bit.
In 1924, a pound moved to Italy. Um,
there, um, he, uh, became, uh,
urgently concerned with economic reform
in the United States and in the West.
Uh, generally, uh, he, uh, uh,
is in this period, uh,
working on his great poem, uh,
his long poem, which I'll be
discussing today, the Qantas,
uh, he became, uh,
increasingly involved in Italian fascism,
uh,
which he, uh, found a, um, um,
powerful,
uh,
vehicle of his own economic
ideas. Uh, in particular,
uh, he made broadcasts in support of, um,
Mussolini's government, uh,
on fascist, uh, radio, uh,
in the 1940s.
And in 1945 at the conclusion of
the war was arrested for treason,
uh, by the United States army. Um,
the charge of treason was,
was dropped, uh, when, uh,
he was, uh, uh, found to be
insane and, um, hospitalized, uh, at, uh,
Saint Elizabeth's hospital
in Washington DC, where,
uh, he would in a very
peculiar way hold court,
uh, a great man of letters,
uh, at the, uh, center, uh,
of, um, uh, well, um,
the American capital,
uh, entertaining, uh, Elizabeth
Bishop, uh, and other, uh,
figures whom we will read, um, at this,
at the time of, um, uh,
pounds institutionalization.
Uh,
his poem,
the piece and Cantos a late stage of
the cantos a was selected as the first
winner of the Bollington
prize. Uh, and, uh,
award initially given by
the Library of Congress, uh,
when pound, um, trader to the nation, uh,
was awarded this prize for
the best American poetry.
Uh, an enormous, uh, literary
and cultural controversy, uh,
sprang up. Um, uh,
which people go on arguing
about. Um, well, uh,
here is, um, uh, a, a, a poet, uh,
who by his own declaration and example,
uh,
seems to be, uh, a fascist
sympathizer and anti-semite.
Could he write great poetry,
uh,
even great poetry that expressed
fascistic and antisemitic,
uh, views, uh,
if he could write that
great poetry of that kind,
should we honor it?
Um,
if he was mad,
is there some way in which his
poetry might not be mad? Well,
these are our questions that, that, uh,
have, uh, uh, persisted. And as I say,
people go on arguing
about them. Um, the, um,
um, uh, controversy, uh,
created so much trouble.
The library of Congress didn't want
any thing to do with the award anymore.
And it moved to Yale.
Uh, and, uh, the, uh,
Beinecke library has
been administrating this,
the arguably the most prestigious
of a poetry prizes ever since.
Uh, and in fact, um, the judging
for this year's award is, uh,
going,
uh,
strong at the moment and there will be
a new winner at the end of the week.
Well,
uh,
pounds anti-capitalism his,
his economic ideas I think are a,
in some ways the intellectual origin
of both his interest in fascism,
uh, and the antisemitic views that, uh,
he expresses both in
poetry and often in prose,
uh,
anti-capitalism for pound.
Uh,
this derives from a really a
specific cultural setting that is,
um, late 19th century
American culture. Uh, uh,
a culture where as pound
experienced it and, and, and,
and sought a art was conceived
as a decorative art, uh,
subject to the editorial tastes of
popular magazines like the Atlantic
or Harper's. Um, uh,
a culture in which poetry was
a kind of commodity, uh, uh,
which status destroyed, uh, the, uh, uh,
potential for originality and
which subordinated art to,
uh, to money when, when
pound expatriates, when he,
when he leaves the United States,
uh, he's fleeing not only America,
but he's as he understands that he's,
he's fleeing American money.
Uh,
and what he is entering a,
what he's going to,
um,
he conceives as a particular
kind of tradition,
a kind of historical community,
uh,
which he describes a in that
first a quotation on your handout,
uh, a, uh, a quotation that, um,
in which pound replies in a,
in a,
a wonderfully hottie way to
the motto of Poetry magazine,
a motto that comes from the
Great American poet Whitman,
uh, to have great poetry. There
must be great audiences to
two,
which pounds says,
it is true that the great artist
always has a great audience.
Even in his lifetime,
but it is not the Volvo that's us.
Uh,
but rather the spirits of
irony and if destiny of humor,
the great authors of the past
sitting beside him a pound,
I think in, in a, in a very, uh,
almost a literal sense conceived
of his audience as, uh,
uh, a, uh,
kind of distinguished community of
readers and writers existing across time.
I kind of trans historical
community of artists,
um, ideas that we'll want to compare
with Elliot's ideas of tradition,
which are related but a little
different. Uh, next week. Well,
um, let me move to, uh,
the second quotation also
from the same period.
1914 pounds has,
there's no use in a strong
impulse in poetry, strong impulse.
I think he means a strong
feeling, strong motive, uh,
emotion if it is nearly all lost in
bungling transmission and technique.
This obnoxious word that I'm always
brandishing about technique means nothing
but a transmission of the impulse intact.
Impound.
There's an emphasis,
as we saw last time in looking
at his rules for writing images,
poetry.
There's an emphasis on the
priority of poetic technique, uh,
and the importance of technical
knowledge. Uh, but, uh,
as this quotation suggest, and it's
important to keep in mind technique.
Impound is always in the
service of intensity,
immediacy or what he calls the impulse
there. Further quotations from pound, uh,
describing his technical aims. Uh,
as I suggested a few minutes ago,
pound moves on from images and
to what he calls vorticism.
Uh, now, uh, instead of, uh, um,
wanting to get at a poetry
that is centered on the image,
he imagines a poetry centered on
now the vortex as he calls it.
And there's a, there's a kind of
definition of the vortex there.
In the third quotation,
uh,
not so much later he would replace
idea of the vortex with another related
image, uh, which is the video. Graham, uh,
we talked about some of pounds,
translations from the Chinese
and Japanese last time.
Pound was interested in,
um, uh, Chinese writing, uh,
systems, uh, as well.
You can imagine how the ideogram appealed
to a poet who wanted to imagine a poem
as, um, an image of a thing, uh, here, uh,
as pound understood it. Uh,
not always, uh, with, uh,
a superb scholarly, uh, uh, precision. Uh,
the Chinese, uh, uh, word, uh,
was in fact an image of
a thing. And, and this,
this is very much a kind of
aesthetic ideal for pound who wanted,
um,
language to give us a kind of immediate
access to the things of the world.
Well,
um,
yeah,
I asked you to read for
class today. One of, uh,
pounds poems from the teens,
one of his famous poems. Uh,
a poem.
Okay.
Uh, called the seafarer, um,
identified in your Ras packet,
uh, as from the angle of sacks.
And I'll, I'll read just the,
the beginning of it for you.
Okay.
May I, for my own self songs,
truth, reckon, journeys,
jargon, how I, in harsh days,
hardship endured oft bitter breast cares.
Have I abided,
known on my Keel.
Many a cares hold and dire,
see surge and their eye off spent narrow
nightwatch nigh the ship's head while
she tossed close to cliffs.
Coldly afflicted.
My feet were by frost.
Benumbed chill.
It's chains are chafing. Size. Whew.
My heart round and hunger be
got mirror weary mood last man,
no, not that he on dry
land. Loveliest liveth list.
How I care Richard on ice cold.
See whether the winter wretched
outcast deprived my kinsmen and so on.
Uh, I ambig pentameter. Uh,
you've been working on
it. Uh, no. Uh, it's not,
uh, what you're listening to is
something very different. Uh,
the sound is rough like frost.
Okay.
And to like frost,
uh,
in this poetry pound is writing against
the beautiful sonorous forms of late
19th century poetry. Uh, but pound's poem,
unlike Frost,
is the very furthest from the
vernacular that we could possibly get.
Uh,
what we have here is pound translating
from the Anglo Saxon and providing a
contemporary equivalent of a
old English alliterative verse.
A particular, uh, verse form, a
dead poetic form. You could say,
uh, uh, although pound revives it
and, and in fact brings it into,
um, a usage, uh, in,
in 20th century poetry.
Uh, this, uh, verse form, I've
given you John Hollander, um,
um,
helpful self descriptive definition,
uh,
at the bottom of your handout where
Hollander says the oldest English accented
meter of for unfailing,
fairly audible,
strongly struck stresses,
seldom attended to anything other than
definite downbeats. In other words,
in, uh, uh, old English verse,
you don't count syllables,
you just count strong stresses.
And,
uh,
there are as a rule for per line,
and the line's like Hollander's here,
like pounds that I just read
tend to divide a in the middle,
uh, there's a Sisera
that breaks the, uh, uh,
the line into a and, and Hollander
goes on, uh, describing it.
Um, in addition to these
strong stresses, the um,
uh, line is held together
by alliterative links, uh,
that join, um, the words, um, you know,
strongly and audibly, uh, in
the, uh, across the six zero
lb is an avant garde poet.
He's an experimentalist, uh,
here we have the strange and very
interesting spectacle of the self.
Consciously modernist,
avant garde artist writing in in archaic,
Dead Poetic Form,
uh,
in the teens.
Uh,
pound is writing a kind of experimental
poetry that in many different ways,
um,
seeks alternatives to 19th century.
Norms of poetic practice seeks
alternatives to romantic sentiment,
uh, poetic diction, a smooth musicality,
uh, all, all of the, the, the
virtues and vices that you find in,
in early Yates.
Uh,
what he does is open poetry to a range
of styles and many of them are a Keck.
Uh, many of them, uh, from
languages outside of English.
Uh, you see pound writing,
his version of the province,
Sal troubadour song can a,
uh,
we talked last time about,
um,
pounds version of Chinese
or Japanese poems. Uh,
he writes his own versions of
Roman poetry or here, old English,
uh, through technical means, uh,
through pounds technique.
He gains access to cultures and voices.
Uh, he revives past voices
like the seafair poets,
uh, revives and implicitly
identifies with them.
Here is an ex patriot
poet writing about, um, a,
uh,
writing in the voice of
the Anglo Saxon wanderer,
a figure deprived of his kinsmen,
uh,
who is out in the elements,
um, uh, far from land, uh,
far from, uh, his nation and home,
uh,
writing in the voice of the seafair pound,
um,
ally's himself with what is historically,
um, prior. Uh, and in fact, in English,
he aligns himself with what
is historically primary, uh,
with the oldest English, uh, poetry. Uh,
here he claims it for himself,
uh,
carries it a forward
or as he would put it,
transmits the impulse,
uh,
in an act of translation,
pounds slogan, make it new, uh,
kind of motto for modernism.
Uh, it's important to, uh,
uh, to hear that injunction
to make it new, uh, as, uh,
specifically historical mission
to revive and transmit a,
the past in a living way.
Uh,
the phrase itself make it new
was translated from, uh, the,
uh, the ancient Chinese, uh, and, uh, uh,
is itself a in that sense.
Um,
an instance of what it describes a pounds
conception of the poet is as one who
brings the impulse as he calls it,
a forward across time. Um, uh,
does so in a kind of imaginative
act of seafaring if you like,
uh, leaving home, going
out, crossing over, uh,
pound is, um, a distinctive, uh,
and in a sense,
quite peculiar thing.
He a kind of visionary scholar.
He is an epic poet of the library.
There's a certain kind of contradiction
in this that is a contradiction or
tension. At any rate, um,
between pounds drive towards immediacy,
uh,
towards, uh, um,
well his wish to convey,
uh,
an emotional impulse and
the highly mediated nature,
uh, of his vision, um, pound,
uh, pounds. Poetry is
full of, uh, learned, uh,
and abstruse reference.
Unlike the Norton Anthology,
if you pick up a volume of pound,
you'll find no footnotes.
He just gives you the thing. Uh,
he gives, you know, help with it.
Um, because I think there is, um,
an intention in the poetry to somehow
give you a kind of unmediated access to
the materials that pound is,
is drawing on.
He wants us to feel the excitement he
feels when he sits down in the library and
opens a book. Um, directness,
intensity, purity, immediacy, uh,
these are all pounds ames.
Any achieves them through an intensely
mediated display of technique.
Um, well, uh,
you might contrast again,
frost.
Frost is always concealing
as it were. His, um, uh,
his expertise, uh, his, uh,
his technical knowledge,
whereas a pound is always showing it.
In the case of the seafarer
pound has used a suites,
Anglo Saxon reader, his college
textbook, uh, to write this poem.
It's one he's taken to
Europe with him. Now, uh,
there are several consequences
for all of this. Uh, one impound.
There is the idea that
there are no dead forms.
There are no dead languages.
There are only derivations variations,
translations,
uh, through which the past is
continuously being made. Present,
uh,
to that is the past is
continuously available for
those who can recognize it and
sees it. Uh, specifically
through technical, uh,
powers,
uh,
technical power switch yet in the
process must be transcended in order to
achieve the kind of immediacy,
uh, empower that he seeks.
Um,
in effect,
pound makes technique
a form of inspiration.
This is, this is an interesting
turn in literary history. Uh,
the visionary poet
impound is a scholar poet.
A literary technique is in pound a
secular means of evoking literary
inspiration,
uh,
literary inspiration in the
form of prior literature, uh,
prior literature seen and felt as sacred,
uh,
uh, as sacred, not as in
Milton, a divine authority,
but rather an authority, um, uh,
to be recognized in felt
and seized in books.
The footnote,
the scholarly index,
the Library Archive.
Uh,
these are the muses that pound
appeals to the used bookstore.
Uh, these are the places
that his poems come from. Uh,
the result is a body of work,
uh,
that is always a returning us.
It's readers to it's sources.
Um,
in the very first lecture I referred to,
uh,
what I see as two very general,
in different,
uh,
competing drives or forces in,
in modern poetry. Uh, one, uh,
centripetal, uh, the
other centrifical, uh,
one, uh, kind of, uh,
will on the part of modern
poets to order poetry itself.
Uh,
on the other hand,
a will to order the world,
uh,
order society,
the artist must be concerned
with arts own problems.
On the one hand, uh,
on the other hand, uh,
in lb and in others,
uh,
the artist is a kind of well
legislator to use Shelly's image.
Uh, he, uh,
has a truth that he wants to promulgate
a that will order society properly.
Um, pound embodies these, these,
that too drives as I'm calling them,
uh,
more clearly better than anybody. Uh,
and they're, they're part of his, uh,
interest, uh, and, and power. Uh, and,
and some of the challenge that
he, uh, gives us, uh, both, uh,
uh, aesthetic, uh, challenges
and, and moral and, and, and, uh,
political ones as, as we
think about his career. Uh,
on the one hand, uh, in
impound, uh, there's,
there's a kind of drive to identify that
which is most essential to literature,
uh,
and to tell pound pounds,
readers how to write poems.
This is, this is the,
the pound who wrote those remarks about
images and that we talked about last
time. On the other hand, uh, there is, uh,
the pound who wants to extend the
reach of literature, who wants to,
who writes letters to
statesmen, uh, who, uh, uh,
goes on fascist radio, uh,
to, uh, tell the world,
uh, how things should be
a, this is also the poet,
uh,
who in his poem,
the Cantos wish to create a
poem that would, as he calls it,
include history. That
what an ambition, right?
Extraordinary. Um, uh,
so on the one hand you have have the, the
poet of, uh, in a station of the metro,
the shortest poem, uh,
in, in modern poetry.
And then you have the poet of the
Qantas, the longest poem, uh, in, uh,
modern poetry. Uh, uh, pound
is both of these things,
uh, and, uh,
these impulses that we see in that poem
and in that Short pump and in that long
pump,
they don't just compete in him.
They exist, I think, uh,
in some kind of collaboration.
Um,
the,
in a station of the metro
identifies the image as the primary
unit of a poetry and impounds practice.
It becomes a kind of building block
for larger forms. Uh, and, uh,
for, uh, the epic itself. Uh, he says, uh,
here, um, and your handout
a in a letter to Joyce,
um,
I have begun an endless
poem of no known category,
true, uh, Fan Upia or something or other,
all about everything true.
I wonder what you,
Joyce will make of it. Uh, well,
fan of Pia means
specifically image making a,
and you could understand the Qantas
as they unfold as a kind of, uh,
um, series of images, poems, um,
uh, eh, as the image becomes this,
uh, fertile, um, principal, uh,
that produces and generates
more and more images,
more and more voices.
Uh,
the cantos had, um, well
he says, have no known
category. Uh, it's, it's true.
Uh, it's hard to identify
the genre of the Cantos,
although I've been calling
it an epic so far. Uh,
there's a sense in which in each canto
pound is inventing the form of the poem,
a new, um, uh, inventing it, uh,
in response to the
demands of new materials.
The way to understand this great and,
and maddening and somewhat mad poem,
uh,
which is one of the great
works of modern poetry, uh,
in which we're reading just the smallest
fragment. One way to understand it,
uh,
is as the record of one man's reading,
one man's a encounter with many voices
and his incorporation of them and
engagement and conversation with them.
Uh,
the title of the poem is worth perhaps
dwelling on for a moment. The cantos,
uh, the songs really is what it means. Uh,
the title foregrounds
literary activity itself, uh,
foregrounds acts of
singing, uh, which are, uh,
here as pound imagines it a kind
of renewable, uh, practice, uh,
or process, uh, that can't be reduced
to a particular image or symbol.
So in that sense, this poem is
unlike the wasteland or the bridge,
uh, which, you know, PR produce these, um,
specific central symbols around
which, uh, all of the poems,
ideas and images are organized.
Pound, uh, instead gives us, uh,
something more like a
process, a pound, uh,
as I say, uh, spoke of it as a
poem, including history. Uh, well,
um, uh, this makes it sound as if the
poem where, you know, larger than history,
somehow a kind of frame for history that
would help us understand in order it,
uh, well maybe pound wish this, but
that's not what he produced. Uh,
the poem lacks in organizing view of
history such as you find in Milton or
Virgil, uh, or homer or Dante. Uh,
it would be therefore it much more
accurate to call it a poem that is in some
sense continuous with history.
That's like history. Uh,
uh, in that sense, uh, a poem
that is structurally unbounded,
uh, uh, uh, this, this is I
think the view of history.
It projects history not
as a story of progress,
uh, or, uh, Yates and
apocalypse and cycles. Uh,
but history rather as something like the
palm itself, something that accumulates,
uh,
and repeats itself with variations
in without a definite aim and view.
Um, history in this sense is
something that can be entered,
uh, but not begun. Uh,
and it can't ever be completed either.
Uh,
and this is true of this poem.
And then went down to the ship,
set Keel to breakers
fourth on the Godly C,
and we set up mass and sail on
that Swerte ship. Borsch sheep,
a board her and our bodies also heavy
with weeping and wins from stern word
Boris onward with bellying canvas.
Searcy's this craft,
the trimmed quaffed goddess then sat
we amid ships when jamming the tiller.
Thus with stretch sale,
we went over,
see till days and son to his slumber
shadows or all the ocean came.
We then to the bounds of deepest water
to the chameleon lands and people,
cities covered with close web,
midst and pierced ever
with glitter of sunrays,
nor with stars stretched nor
looking back from heaven.
Swore this night's stretched
over wretched men there.
The ocean flowing backward came we
then to the place aforesaid by Searcy.
When I was a student, I, I said
to, um, uh, my teacher, uh,
I don't really get pound. It's, and
it's not very beautiful, uh, either. Uh,
and he said, well, take
a look at this. Uh, and,
and produced those lines I just
read, which are magnificent, heroic,
uh, poetry. Um,
they begin with that word and they begin
with the conjunction and they begin
with a conjunction and
without a grammatical subject,
and then went down to the ship,
who went down to the ship.
Pound doesn't say,
uh,
he introduces the poem with
an action, an action, uh,
that is itself part of a series.
The action that we are being introduced
to here is Odysseus is journey to hell.
Uh, in search of Tyree,
uh, the profit, uh,
among the souls of the dead.
He wants to learn.
A deceased wants to learn his,
uh,
future course and decide how to act a dcs.
We learn as the poem unfolds.
A is first speaker,
uh,
pound accesses and, and,
and, uh, gives to us.
Um,
which is to say that we're
reading a translation again.
Uh,
and how does a speak not
like Tennyson's Ulysses,
uh,
in sonorous blank verse,
but rather as I think you could
hear, uh, readily enough, uh,
in the Anglo Saxon alliterative verse
form of the seafarer pounds doing
something very interesting,
uh, an exhilarating,
he is translating what he
conceives of as the, uh,
oldest passage in the Odyssey,
uh,
that most archaic,
of poetry in the West and translating it,
uh, using, um, that poetry most, uh,
archaic in English, uh, the,
uh, language and rhythms, uh,
and patterning of the seafarer.
This is a kind of, you know,
overlay in technique, uh, again, uh,
of old English, a litter to verse, uh,
and Homer's Greek.
Um,
these linguistic forms
in the poem are merged
as if by a kind of pair of taxes,
which I talked about last time,
uh, to produce what pound calls, uh,
when he's writing about
the image as a complex, uh,
uh, a complex of elements that
are held together in an instant,
uh,
an instant that as he understood it
transcends space and time limits.
Uh, this is all set out again
in the doctrine of the image.
Uh, and, and we, we talked
about another instance of that,
a kind of cultural overlay,
a of materials in,
uh,
the little poem in a station
of the metro contrast.
What pound is doing here with
what Joyce does in Ulysses, uh,
in Ulysses, uh, Joyce is
in a sense caring, um,
uh, Homer's texts, uh, into
contemporary Dublin. Uh,
he's, you know, naturalizing
it, modernizing it. Um,
pound in a sense is doing just
the opposite. Uh, he is, uh,
going back, uh, and indeed
here the sea flows backward.
Uh, and it, it takes us back to a, again,
primary terms, uh, Archaic
Greek, uh, archaic,
uh,
English.
He is seeking to reappropriate,
uh, the heroic mode,
uh, through translation, uh, in, uh,
yet, uh, contemporary idiom.
This is a kind of raising of the dead,
a kind of journey to the
literary and cultural underworld,
uh, that brings pounds,
adventure as a poet,
a interline with Odysseus's. I
mean, you can see, in other words,
what a deceased is doing now as he goes
to the underworld and seeks prophetic
speech from [inaudible] as a
version of what pound is doing,
as he seeks to translate the Greek,
uh,
at the inception of his epic
pounds own display of technique.
You can understand as a kind of a
version of the ceremony to honor and pay
tribute to through blood sacrifice,
uh,
that a deceased practices here,
in the pages that follow a,
as he induces Tyree Ceus to appear and,
and speak,
um, literary tradition here, uh,
has itself taken the place
of the transcendental
source of authority that was
classical, uh, or the Christian Muse, uh,
here pound, uh, in a sense
turns back upon poetry itself,
uh, as a sacred source
here, uh, at a moment, uh,
in the epic where in vocation
would ordinarily a stand, uh,
at the point of inception, uh, here, uh,
technique is imagined a as a
kind of process of translation,
uh, through which a speech
from elsewhere is, uh,
brought forward in time.
Uh, and in some sense,
um, carried across, uh, waters. Um,
again, there's a sense of
contradiction, however,
or tension pound wants to elicit
speech from the dead to make,
uh,
the traditions language new.
He wants to transmit the impulse.
He also insists,
however,
Cannelly and,
and provocatively on the
mediated quality of his words.
Uh, Tyree Sia speaks,
uh, at the, uh, uh, uh,
top of page three 70,
uh,
towards the end of the poem he says to
a deceased when he sees him a second
time,
why man of ill star facing the sunless
dead and this joyless region stand from
the fos. That is the ditch a leave
me, my bloody beaver for through say,
and I stepped back and that I,
there is the,
I have a deceased and he
strong with the blood,
said then Odysseus shall return through
spiteful Neptune over dark seas,
lose all companions.
And then Anta Claya a deceased.
His mother came and then a
remarkable thing happens.
Someone says, lie quiet, diverse,
I mean, and now the eye is the eye
of pound. The narrator, the speaker,
not Odysseus.
I mean,
that is Andrei has diverse in a fit.
Kina Vecoli 15,
38 out of homer.
This is pound stepping
into the poem saying,
I have been translating all of this from
homer and I have been using the first,
uh, uh, well the, the, the
Latin translation, uh, uh, of,
uh, Andrei Us Davis, uh, that, uh,
I bought in a Paris bookstand.
Uh,
and this has been my source for this text,
and it is a diverse that I have the
translator that has been my, uh,
Muse, uh, and who has
been speaking here, uh,
through Tyree Ceus, uh, if you like.
And it's his soul that is
laid back and to rest. Uh,
and at this moment, um,
pound continues, uh,
now speaking of a deceased in
the third person, then he says,
and he sailed by sirens and events
outward in way and unto Searcy.
Um, finally, uh, the journey continues,
uh, here, uh, uh, again, um, uh,
deceases journey being
analogized implicitly to the, uh,
journey that the translator is
affecting as he brings the text, uh,
forward in time across from
oral culture to print, uh,
from Greek to Latin and Latin
to English and old English. Uh,
and then, uh, in a, uh,
remarkable efflorescence that, uh,
ends this first Canto, uh, with, uh,
a macro ironic display of languages.
Pound says vendor on dumb.
In the Cretans phrase again,
he's opened his, his book, uh,
uh, and, and at the back of, uh,
a diverse as translation, he's
found, um, uh, the, uh, uh,
Homeric hymns and now he's going to
give them to us with the Golden Crown
Aphrodite kip pre Muna Menta sore Tita
s mirthful or Kalki with golden girdles
and breast bands, thou with dark eyelids
bearing the Golden Bough of Argus Sita.
So that colon,
the poem ends here with a
prayer to the goddess of beauty.
Aphrodite,
who is invoked here in Greek and Latin,
uh, who is, uh, brought forward
and who is named Artists Sita,
a killer of the Greeks,
a slayer of the Greeks,
presumably because she has, uh, uh,
had her hand in, uh, uh,
the abduction of Helen.
And, uh, the war in Troy, uh, um,
here, uh, pound has, um, uh,
invoked the goddess,
uh, in these ways, uh,
and then concluded his Canto,
uh,
with the interesting grammatical form.
So that and the interesting
punctuation colon, um,
in effect,
it's a poem began with,
and it now ends with,
so that where the colon is a kind of a
gateway through which the rest of the
poem and implicitly,
uh, following a homer,
the rest of history, uh,
we'll pass. Uh, and here,
pound has established his poem
and established his own role. Uh,
as in some sense a
mediator I'm conducting,
uh, a, a process by
which, um, the, the, uh,
uh, sources of the past are, uh,
brought forward into the future,
uh,
relaying what he calls the impulse
and in the process making it new.
Well, uh, let's stop. Uh, and
we will, um, uh, go on to,
as I say, the related and different, uh,
poetry of Tsla at next week.